woman stuck upside down in exercise
machine calls 911 for help dude I love
that she had her phone on her stick
around guys want to talk to you about
our sponsor hyms you're confident in the
office at the dinner table and even on
the dance floor but can you keep it
going when you get back to the bedroom J
that's right with HS you can get access
to medications to ensure your erectile
dysfunction gets treated Ed so you can
keep the confidence going all day and
all night start your free online visit
today at hs.com DPT that's
hs.com DPT for your personalized ed
treatment options hs.com
DPT restrictions apply see website for
details and important safety information
hey Tes welcome to another episode of
people
Town population you population pton
Johnny pton
is it John Q pton John Q pton it's uh
it's Jimmy Jason Jack crack corn pton
the second okay good and those are
Minnesota Vikings colors on yours for
those watching hoodie this a viking
sweatshirt we're representing it quick
Tripp in the Vikings nothing says
Minnesota Vikings More Than Sunshine
yellow exactly this there is a little
yellow in the beard right Vikings the
colors are purple so when when there is
a yellow out at a Vikings game people
really go nuts right they really try and
yell they do a white out now they don't
do a yellow they do a yellow out should
they do a white out that's just people
in Minnesota I ask a question that many
Townes who are also sports fans maybe
even the two of you will make fun of me
for you may as well but I do not know
this what what is why do you guys yell
skull cuz it's a it's a Nordic thing
it's a Nordic thing like I swear to God
based on how I was raised Northern
illino because of that because of the
culture of living in the Midwest and
Wisconsin and my family and people in
Minnesota and I was like I guess at
probably sometime in the early 90s they
just started cheering for how much they
loved dip well it means it means long
cut in Norwegian
that's I did you see me look at you like
Dan was like uhuh you saw it Dan said uh
of course I did Dan it is Viking for
like charge look I have no problem
admitting you're dumb I have a problem
with people who stay that way so
learning like right no dumb question you
are always that's what I love about you
you are always Evol I'm like Johnny who
has been like an AA stasis from the time
15 years old you were evolving he you
guys y
skull yeah it's kind it is a newer thing
though it's a thing that started I don't
know I've been a Vikings fan for about
three and a half years to be honest I
got into them but now I like really
liked them a lot I love it what a great
thing to come to them late in life I
think it's a good I think it's a good
team for are not good right well so I
became a fan of the Lions a couple years
ago and and they were not good when I
became a fan and now they are good and
everyone thinks I'm bandwagoning but I
was in on them when they didn't make the
why made you join the Lions as a as a
You Started Loving all things Michigan
because of well because they drafted one
of my favorite players in recent time
from Michigan Aiden Hutchinson the
defensive end I'm like this is a guy
who's going to change the culture here I
know it I know he did it at Michigan I
know it I know it I know it and he did
he was part of it all right should we
jump into a dum stb people are doing
dumb things then we'll talk about what
you're
doing SK into this story all right this
is sent in by Lissa at the girl on the
wall and you want her on that wall you
need her on that wall uh here's the
headline man claiming to be time
traveler throws brick through window to
save homeowners I mean in his mind he's
doing it right look I I love
sci-fi we're probably justifiably about
to make fun of this person but what if
he
time TR the question is what's he saving
them from what right and by throwing a
brick through a window what are you
really doing you're really just damaging
property so but they were going to go to
dinner and then they were going to get
uh killed on the way to that dinner
throwing a brick through their window
will ruin that night and they will not
go to that tener true so maybe they I
understand what you're saying you're
trying to throw wrench into their plans
to keep them through the window a wrench
into the window a wrench it shouldn't be
a a fly in the ointment it should be a
brick in the window let's put a brick in
the window hey we're just another brick
in the window we're just another brick
in the
window the window ain't it hey it's a
brick in a window it's a brick in a
window a window brick all right so
here's the other thing when you see a
crazy person on the street like you
ain't going to tell me that shut your
mouth Charlene or whatever God damn like
well Charlene is a [__] what they're
hearing on the other side is the other
half of that conversation right they're
hearing Charlene say I've never liked
you you're a bad person and they're
respond to something so in their world
it's very real oh yeah I made mistake of
having a conversation with a person who
was talking to themselves once when I
first moved La I was like and the guy
would got so mad at me and you jumped in
you're [__] up the other conversation
he's having you're interrup interruped I
interrup you interrupted the person who
wasn't there all right uh a man and
we'll get into how old he is later
claiming to be a time traveler was
arrested after he told Okala police that
he threw a brick through a home window
to save the occupants from a home window
from a future event this is a Flo story
righta Florida Cal Florida yeah on
Saturday May 13th a day that we'll live
on in sa you'll never forget remember
where we are an oal police deparm
officer responded to a local residence
in reference to a possible burglary upon
arrival the officer made contact with
the victims who own the home according
to the rest report the victims told the
officers that a loud crash woke them up
worst sound you could ever hear and they
heard their baby crying all right so now
oh that's bad this is crazy
why he's trying to save the whole family
I don't what you guys aren't getting
here you know that if the guy's just
standing there when the police come and
says what you guys don't understand
that's the way the every conversation
starts yes right so uh when they checked
on their baby they observed that a
bassinet filled with stuffed animals was
on the ground and the window was smashed
that so he threw the brick through the
baby window God damn it God damn it what
if the baby is the reason changes it
they kill him the baby kills him talk
about Baby Hitler yeah I was about to
say is this is this baby Hitler Gold's
bit you know Dana's bit the that great
bit about like if I someone showed him a
picture of a little baby it's like how
adorable is this baby and he's like it's
a cute baby he's like what if I told you
that's Charlie Manson as a baby he'd be
like oh my go he was like that's insane
and he's like if I could go back in time
I would go back in time and take Charli
The Time Machine go back and take the
bab Charlie Manson and Baby Hitler and I
would use the baby Trine to beat and
Destroy Baby Hitler he's like sure at
the time it would look
weird true it's great uh they advised
that a large brick was also found on the
floor according to the OPD report in
addition the victim stated that they
found a book outside their home near the
front door that did not belong to them
tring this is important The Time
Traveler's Wife it should be Time
Traveler's Wife or Hitchhiker's Guide to
the Galaxy what should it be the Pelican
Brief or something you know innocuous
yeah the shooting script to the firm
it's the game the game by mystery yes oh
my God and Neil Strauss
mystery uh got to NE him you got to that
this family got that through NE that
baby the officer walked around the per
perimeter of the victim's home and noted
the report that the gate to the backyard
was open the officer observed the broken
window the window screen was found on
the ground the back door to the victim's
pool was also open the victims informed
the officer that prior to the incident
the gate was Secure and the screen was
on the window obviously yeah we don't
leave a screen on the ground and we
don't leave a door brick didn't come
from the baby's bassinet yeah the brick
isn't coming from inside the house we
know that though exactly that's what I'm
trying to we know do we know do we know
who this guy knows who this baby's going
to be right is this baby reading thank
you that book is that book from the
future and it's the baby's book oh my
God I wish it several officers canvased
the neighborhood and attempt to Lo
locate a nearby security camera and a
residence was observed that had an open
front door the officers made contact
with one of the homes occupants who
identified himself as Daniel Robert
dinkin oh my gosh mayor of New York
Daniel that's 2third of my name Daniel
Robert yes my last name is Van Kirk So
Daniel unless this guy is you from the
future Dan Dan and he did this cuz he
knew he was going to make on the show
who okay shut it down shut it down shut
it down shut it down as Gordon Ramy says
shut it down sh it down according to the
OPD report the officers told dinkin
mayor dinkin mayor Mr dinkin would you
please be my mayor uh that they were in
the neighborhood investigating a
burglary that had occurred down the road
dinkin spontaneously told the officers
that may have been
me now that may have been me that may
but I'm not back yet from the future so
I don't know if that was me that may
have been me he further informed the
officers that he had gone swimming at
the victim's home and threw a brick
through the window oh this is a classic
crazy right this is a nut so when
someone says there may have been start
to get bummed out cuz I really was like
may have wait there may have been a a
burglary in the neighborhood and you go
all the way to I that may have been me I
threw a br brick through the window and
I also was swimming in their pool well
look I missed that part he swam in the
pool I swam in the he's also soaking wet
in his clothes this might as well be the
Joker here for all he's got another
brick in his hand anding the hands were
two in the after being read his Miranda
rights dingin admitted that he breaking
the hand is worth two in the bassinet
you know that you know that Dan he
admitted to I really wanted him to be a
time travel that he broke into the
victim's residence to go swimming in
their pool that's all he wanted to do
hey man pool quick quick question
interjection your honor if I may sure
did any of you at any point in your life
pool hop no you jump in other people's
pools like you go around town in high
school and you just jump from one you
swim pool get out run go to another Pool
did not no I was like convincing pretty
fun thing of course terrifying you're
the oh my God you're in high school it's
you and like a couple girls you have
crushes on and every it's a whole group
of people running around jumping into
pools and maybe you're a little you know
you don't need to underage drink but
it's roell so it's trespassing but it's
a victimless crime of some sort you just
getting the experience and coming and
you take a little [__] in the pool right
tiny little [__] every takes a little
bit of a [__] a tiny brick through the
baby's bassinet right leave a book on
the front step just kids being leave a
book on the front St just kid being kids
uh and he left the book on the front
door because he quote wanted to share
the book with them is it the
autobiography of Le I like this guy this
is a full crazy this is like the fullon
like this man is it's the Diary of an
Frank he's done so many things here that
like if it was just one you'd be like
all right this guy's nuts but then the
swimming and the
book makes him huge yeah it better be
The Da Vinci Code yeah that's right uh
This Is The Da Vinci Code dinkin further
admitted that he had grabbed a brick and
used it to break the window so basically
said there may have been a burglary down
the street and this guy won't start when
did he start talking about time
traveling the OPD reports said that
dingin told investigators that he was a
time traveler and needed to save the
victims from an event that is going to
occur in the future can you tell us what
that event need more details we need
more details during the post mirand
interview dinkin advised that he was
unaware that a baby was inside the room
when he broke the window cuz in his eyes
it's an older person 23-year-old kid how
could you have not known he also told
investigators he was trying to save the
baby from something way in in the future
when the child is much older what God
this is I need more details I mean I
kind Dan I'm I'm sort of on his side he
he has good intentions yeah he has good
drugs too what this is a whatever he's
cooking sort of thing it feels let him
cook let him cook dkin was arrested
transported to Maran County Jail where
he was released on the same day on how
much Bond what's the bond for something
like this Dam 10 grand grand 5 grand 20
grand get your ansers in you guys are
all hovering around it $115,000 okay
there you go he's facing a felony charge
for burglary of an occupied dwelling
Court data is not yet been scheduled but
I'm sure he knows when it is he does
he's already done he's been in court ACC
in jail record he knew this is going to
happen I'm going to show you a picture
of him he looks a little like Seth
Morris with a with a goatee um can you
see him oh yeah it is kind of sethy he
looks like he works at Universal's
Halloween Horror Night and he definitely
is like audition just has the soul patch
that's all he's got downstairs right
right uh that guy's definitely on mad
you saw his picture let guess how old is
that how old is Mr dinkin would you my
mayor Daniel Robert dinkin 26 that's a
good guess that's a good gu 26 years old
okay 23 damn it that's what I was going
to say sorry Michael Jordan I'll go
swoosh swoosh that's what he said when
the brick went through the baby's
room swo I really I mean I I hate to do
but I point 24 he's 24 years old all
right get your answers in cuz he is from
the future from your ages oh yeah okay
this man is 37 years
old that kid is not zoom I was guessing
drugs that he looks old travel is
treating him well mhm it's a good look
it's a good how old how old is he 37
years old I can see he looks good he
looks good come on Dan Dan he looks good
they not a gray hair on his far that's
far away not a gray hair on Dan open
sorry sorry all right okay fine please
look at this man he looks good he's 37
looks like a that's a baby face maybe
he's the baby you're right he looks like
what if he's the baby Matt Dylan Like if
that's a Matt Dylan character yeah look
is very Matt Dyan da it's early Dylan I
miss Matt Dylan we need more Matt Dylan
don't we I uh Bob more Boby I just saw
Matt Dylan yeah in
coffee really at uh what's that place
what's that place people that like you
have to have a membership
I man's it going all right hey man how's
it going all right we're going to take a
break I like this girl I like this girl
a lot but I don't know she's [__]
crazy
godamn [__] crazy I need to get a
gun you don't [__] all right [__] [__]
put your name
in Johnny pamon is with us we have uh
more D impression we're going to tell
him what he's got going on and uh we'll
give our stuff that we have on the other
side of the making St people don't go
[Music]
anywhere hey y'all welcome back to the
show Johnny pton is with us we're going
to talk about what he has going on so
you can support him and watch the things
that he's made and is doing and tour and
all that stuff uh let's tell them about
us uh here's the good stuff about that
we have going on we're going to be in
Denver on if this drops before that on
uh February 1st 2 and third at comedy
work South and then the beginning of uh
of March we're going to be at the first
club we ever uh performed and got paid
at Mark rley Comedy Castle in Detroit we
haven't been there in like over 30 years
or 30 years so going to be fun yeah go
Lions Detroit's happy it's a happy Town
we're excited to go there uh then we're
in Acme Comedy Club at the beginning of
April and then moon tower at the end of
April and then just added we're going to
Salt Lake City Jordan Landing that club
The Wise Guys Club there will be there
in May May 17 18th uh
supercars.net that you guys are strong
and long and mean and all that other
stuff and we'll tell you other stuff
that we have coming on and coming up
like our twom man show which we're
working on right now all that stuff will
become apparent as we continue on Johnny
tell the people where that we can find
you new stuff you got going on all of it
you can find me right here right now
I'll be in Chicago February 14th through
the 17th doing my oneman show at the Den
it's a Minnesota ree colostomy bag yes
performing it live at the Den Theater in
Chicago
the show born out of what standup and
other stuff yeah it's it's like a hybrid
sort of format but it's you know it's uh
it's definitely standup comedy but it's
uh you know no mic does that no mic yeah
you're walking the prow in the exactly
no mic that's the main difference I love
it phenomenal at the Den theater you can
see it then uh other dates beyond that
um nothing confirmed right now that I
can I can remember at least okay all
right so Chicago show up
Chicago and the theater is a great place
place to see stuff so we did a live dumb
people down there people love that place
love love that theer great setup and a
great store right across great clothing
store right across the street there
check that out too uh shall I jump into
this yeah Second Story all right sent in
by Matthew Freeman at not your aage mat
and it's AVG Matt on 96 you ready for
this mhm and this guy you got to love
the gumption I'm just going to say right
now Florida man who tried to cross the
Atlantic in a hamster wheel is
arrested I'm going to run across the how
come why would you get arrested though
so a Florida man was arrested I mean
this is what people do not really
understand did we do this story before I
don't think we did we've done we did one
oh maybe we did do this story actually I
think we did it does sound familiar to
me is this a recent phenomenon I don't
think we did this story I don't you know
what even if we did it's going to be new
jokes or you will see that our minds
always work in the same way but wait
this is when people truly do not
understand distances right right yes
like remember when Diane and niad tried
to there's a whole movie about her
trying to swim to Cuba and there's all
the jellyfish in there and she kept
getting stung and she was like this
unbelievable swimmer that could swim
like so far and then she became an NPR
reporter she's like I can swim 90 mes to
CU 90 M to Cuba I'm like I don't know so
I swim across and back uh my Lake uh up
in Wisconsin okay so much that's a long
story I would bet you that across cross
and back I actually knew this cuz my
watch saved it but I think it was maybe
it's not a huge Lake Cross and back I
think it was maybe like a third of a
mile okay yeah still so there is a point
you're and I know every I've done it my
almost my whole life but there is a
point where you go I'm going to drown no
you just go like man this is a little
bit farther than I thought you know what
I'm saying like we you're like I'm out
here in the middle of this Lake and I
can't go back and I do it I do a thing
it tethers around my waist and it's like
a floating big bright colored like neon
colored buoy that you should always have
with you if you're doing long long
distance swimming because um one it
tells everybody even though there's
hours on my L where it's no wake so I
shouldn't have to worry you never know
and then the other thing is is if I did
cramp up ouren to break you can hold on
to it and float and you wouldn't need
anything on yes I use it every time I I
swim across but I'm just saying even in
that which is very short short there is
a point where you're like I still got a
ways to go I got go so someone thinking
oh I'll go to Cuba or I'll go across the
Atlantic has I don't think has any true
concept of what distance so here's what
he wanted AES Florida man arrested after
trying to quote R forget [__] forget
storm you could be a mile out and you're
like oh I'm the storm's going to kill me
but he's in a hamster wheel he's fine
yeah it's fine by the
way why is this in my feed like now all
of these videos of like huge waves like
crashing through fairies because they're
awesome it's you like once and they're
like oh you like that you like that you
like that you like a ship getting all
right so Florida man was trying to run
to London that's the thing the run to
London acoss the Atlantic oce a homemade
vessel resembling a hamster whe US Coast
Guard from Florida too would you start
at Florida to get to is that even longer
you got to go up you fly yourself up
north if you do it like a plane if you
do it like a plane you actually will
make it shorter you go a little bit up
to come a little bit down get the
hamster wheel there it's got to be hard
to get the hamster wheel he should be
going like Alaska to Russia right that's
30 Mi yeah US Coast Guard intercepted
raaza beluchi about how many miles off
taibe Island Georgia so he left from
Georgia on Georgia he left so he's got
to go around no he's no he can go to
Savanah up okay still go NOS I'm go go
go NOS I went to flor State man all
right so how did how many miles off of
the coast I think about 6971 maybe you
better be [__] 699 or 71 yeah what
are you going to pick I'm going to pick
71 okay what do you think three and even
then I'm like impressed I was going to
say one yeah I was my first thought was
is zero an option one of you is one mile
off so now you okay what do you think
it's 70 cuz I saw it over your shoulder
oh God damn you godamn you you know what
you're an honest man
70 miles he went far dude so I have to
hold it like this but why is that
illegal though why can't he why can't he
do that because what get you should be
to do that it's your it's your well I
think one reason you have to there's
like a I'm sure it's federally some sort
of regulation of knowing people that you
like you're in shipping lanes right
right I mean it's like it be like can I
run a marathon through an airport uh no
you can't run a marathon through like oh
but I'm just running a marathon you
can't run on the tarmac but that's
private property the ocean international
waters that's I don't know so we're
going so we're going to find there is an
argument to be said with you said that
if you want to go do this let me live my
life and you know you may
die we not making it illegal for people
to parachute we don't make it for
illegal for people to uh do the gliding
jump off stuff where it's like mean Sr
suits and all [__] and they always go
and what do they say they're like oh uh
they always have like trucker demone
whatever their name is trucker demone
that is the best name ever trucker Deone
my name's trucker demone trucker that's
who always does these types of lives
that's X Games always have they always
have the craziest name trucker a trucker
Deone his first name is trucker yes he
died doing what he loved and then people
just accept it but they also they're
like I'm going to die doing this right
and I it's going to be a great so I
agree I am I am getting way on board
with you that they that he sort of is
like hey if you want to go do I mean
you're going to die then the resources
are going to have to be used to clean
think about that [__] sub the one
that went you know I know the
submersible they lied about all that
stuff I know dude they used like a
Nintendo like game boy to like control
it all right official say thee and we'll
guess his age later I'm not looking over
your shoulder anymore marathon runner
refused to leave refused to leave the
vessel for how many days so they made
contact with him and then for how many
days he just kept going he's like this
gu badass now I'm not leaving this thing
I am impressed with 70 miles how many
days did he 12 days what do you think
four six six one of you is one day off
one of you is one day off seven
five is it me again no no just one of
you is one day off three three three
three three what do you think I think
you go one up or one down I think it's
me I'm go 11 or or or I think 11 11 get
your answers in Towes because he would
not leave the vessel for 3 days Daniel
very good yeah nice Dan Mr beluchi I
feel like that's being too kind to the
guy too formal beluchi Hey where's my
brother according to according to Reza
just kidding uh Mr beluchi according to
uh has tried three similar voyages
before all of which ended in Coast Guard
intervention okay the makeshift
Contraption he was using was shaped as a
wheel with paddles that are designed
designed to propel it so what's
happening either Coast Guard's seeing
him or other vessels are see a river
radioing Coast Guard he doesn't want
them to find out they're like this [__]
but it's like gigantic and you're going
to see it he needs to do this on like
Christmas day where most people are not
going to be out on the water and lower
staff for the Coast Guard doing it in
September cops P up and they're like you
lose your river boat yeah exactly what's
going on there buddy how we what what's
happening anyway do you know how fast
you were going uh based on the condition
of the vessel which was afloat as as a
result of wiring in buoys Dan US Coast
Guard uh officers deter beluchi was
conducting a manifestly un safe Voyage
so that's where they can step in we're
protecting you from yourself Mr bucci's
Voyage began as officials were preparing
for the arrival of a major hurricane not
a good idea dude read the [__]
weather man if you're going to build
this thing oh wow we did a story
probably oh my God years and years and
years ago we maybe did this on one of
his earlier ones no I'm saying we did a
story about a guy who went over Niagara
Falls and killed himself and he sold
shirt he created a website called uh
something like his name was like his
name was
like and he was like uh he was like
trucker Deone died on the niagar fall
like he knew he wasn't going to make was
yeah and he sold t-shirts and all this
stuff and there was just a thing of him
like he was going to do this and he was
going to die St like there's a part
where they stood as been like
Hurricane's coming we're going to give
you you come with us you can ride this
out but you didn't want him blown back
into someone's house that's what I'm
saying he's 70 miles
out hurricane
not going hurricane could drop him on
the other side officials say he refused
to step off the vessel and threaten to
kill himself well that's what you're
doing with the vessel yeah yeah I'm
going to kill myself like we know you're
doing you want to do it now or in like
20 days slowly or quickly how do you
want to go he so they were three days
and he had already started I'm trying to
figure out how many days cuz think of
all the protein bars you would have to
bring with you and water and it would
melt and then this is where do you want
to hear how this is where you're kind of
like well you don't have a plan he's
like he also claimed he had a bomb on
board shut up why would you why would
you want a bomb on board right this guy
he's nuts he wanted to get caught on
September 1st he eventually surrendered
and abandoned his vessel after being
brought to a Coast Guard base in Miami
and then taken to a rave kidding uh
officials later determined that the bomb
had been fake so he did have a bomb on
board but it was fake fake bomb again
adding weight yes why are you adding
weight to the thing you got a pedal he's
now facing federal charges of
obstruction of a boarding and violation
of a captain of the port order this is
all like old pirate law and stuff this
is all like the you know like that's my
favorite name for a job is the sador the
stor says you have come forth to this
place now you shall be banished here you
have angered the stor parlay parlay the
stor Claws and allows me to step forth
three steps to you under the law of the
Sun and have and may have sexual Rel
with
your says that I love theor Street in La
called Commodore SLO I love great name
great name it's unclear whether he
obtained a lawyer to represent him in
the criminal case this is a guy who
represents himself right definely and
he's and he's like I only work from a
standing desk that's right well the
courtroom is a regular I'm bringing in
my standing desk I said what I said I
said what I said your honor I need to
speak with my client what are you doing
I'm find my way
up 2021 he was arrested after being
rescued while trying to ride from
Florida to New York after drifting how
many miles south of his departure point
he was trying to go Florida New York he
drifted down from New York how many
miles did he drift South when he was
trying to go just listen to the Jews you
come down from New York to Florida
that's how it worked 17 miles 17 miles
how many miles did he drift he was near
25 miles what do you think I'm going to
say 24 okay get your answers in townies
he drifted 30 miles South south of the
departure point current so this dude
doesn't look at currents also doesn't
look at the [__] WEA patterns in 2014
he had to be rescued from a similar
Contraption near St Augustine oh this
guy and then two years later he had to
be rescued off the coast to Jupiter near
Palm Beach Florida this guy is now the
your kid who won't stop sticking his
finger into the socket this could be a
cool movie yeah to quote Biggy Smalls he
is ready to die right according to
previous interviews Mr beluchi said he
was attempting the Voyages to raise
money for a variety of causes including
for the homeless and the Coast Guard
Coast Guard's like we're good we do not
need you to raise money we're a federal
organization you want me to stop raing
it's for you guys this definitely feel
I'm doing for you guys like an after the
fact what you want me to stop raising
money for you guys
God somewhere there's an ex-wife who's
like you know I haven't talked to him in
years I I have no idea what he's up that
was him oh wow he always said he going
to do explains a lot I thought that was
a joke my goal is to not quote my goal
is to not only raise money for homeless
people raise money for the Coast Guard
raise money for the police department
again Police Department is like do not
rope Us in don't rope us into that
hamster whe you you've you've
Diversified your charitable charitable
donations so much that no ra and raise
money for the fire department how much
money have you raised nothing yet about
30 I love the idea that things raise
money like if you do something crazy
it's like why you doing this it's like
uh money raise money breast cancer
awareness it's like it's not like
someone should just say oh why you doing
this oh cuz it's uh [__] crazy
I'm a Nut and I want to just yeah I want
so do you think that we'll ever have
another evil coneval do you think we'll
ever have another guy we really don't
really much have that illegal Canal
illegal come on that's who this guy is
illegal Canal I think David Blaine is
our most like like crazy can you believe
he did that like but like walking across
a a high wire that's Beena brother yeaha
guy did like yeah they have to continue
to have spawn anyway they are in public
service they do it for safety they help
other people so again he's trying to get
everyone on board with him is like don't
don't throw this guy away he's doing it
for the police department anyway so
that's it we're going to we're going to
get out of here on this all my comedy
shows are start going to be uh I'm
raising money for the police department
and the fire department yeah and for the
Coast Guard I don't think I don't think
this guy should be referred to as a
marathon runner I think he's like why
he's done it fine but like that's not
how you identify this guy just crazy guy
on the ocean like sure like Daredevil
like look you said illegal Canal that's
the way I would describe Marathon bummer
right how old we get out of here on this
how old is Rea
beluchi uh he's a marathon runner he's a
Rebel Rebel and a runner he's a signal
turn in green he's a guy on a hamster
wheel that wants to run a big machine
how old is Reza beluchi we get out of
here on this and then Dan you got the
last story I'm going to guess that he is
41 years old MH what do you think I was
going to guess the same thing honestly
so I'll guess 37 other guy was I was
going to say 37 wow look at this now you
got to get some this resu I'm going say
he's uh he's 33 years old 33 years old
get your answers in Towes we got one
more story Johnny pemon G to see you
guys are going to see him in Chicago at
the denic doing his and 14th through the
17th 14th through the 17th and I it's
like something R Minnesota colos bag bag
good enough what is it Minnesota reg
colos yeah almost got it you almost got
it all right raluchi reggae Minnesota
coloss bag Minnesota reg colos bag is 44
years
old all right we'll be right back with
more Dan got the last story we'll be
right back with more dumb people town
with Johnny
peon sck around make sound there's
more all right guys real talk I got to
tell you this 52% of men over 40
experience some form of Ed between the
ages of 40 and 70 but it's always been
this taboo topic thankfully our friends
at hymns they're changing that by
providing affordable access to ed
treatment all online there's no shame in
wanting to like perform better have a
good happy healthy
relationship romantic when you want to
be a placebo effect also that connects
with something like this which is if you
know that that's not going to be a
problem then you will have an experience
that you can feel like going into it you
can just be in the moment and enjoy
yourself and actually feel good it's a
nice way for you to feel good about
yourself as you go into these encounters
and it does improve relationships it
just does hims is changing men's
Healthcare by providing access to
Affordable and discreet Sexual Health
treatments from uh all from the comfort
of your couch they provide access to
clinically proven alternatives to Viagra
and SE up to
95% cheaper with options as low as $2
per dose two bucks to have a good night
there you go two bucks to have a good
night it seems like an easy decision the
process is simple and 100% online
there's no uncomfortable doctor visits
which is nice you answer your a series
of questions on their site and a medical
provider will determine the right
treatment option if you're prescribed
your medication ships directly to you
for free and in discret packet so you
don't even have to worry about anybody
where your mail or if you live in a
place where people people get boxes and
they're like H okay right we know what
they ordered no insurance is needed pay
one low price uh for your treatments
online visits ongoing shipments and and
provider messaging so you can start your
free online visit at
hims.com DPT that's hs.com DPT for your
personalized ed treatment options hs.com
DPT prescriptions require an online
consultation with a healthcare provider
who will determine if appropriate
restrictions apply see website for
details and important safety information
subscription required price varies based
on product and subscription
plan stick
around hey y'all welcome back to the
show Daniel before you jump into the
final story give us a little taste where
people can find you I'm so excited for
your special to come out in April I
cannot wait for wine club movies out now
though movies out wine club is out right
now I really it feels so good to say
this confidently um if you go and watch
it I believe you will enjoy it yeah you
know we've all done been a pro done
projects and stuff we like H nobody
really needs to check that out leave
that away this is not one of those
things um I'm proud of the work that I
did it I'm proud of my performance I'm
proud of the people I made it everyone
in it is so funny and uh yeah it's just
a really good fun this time of year like
H let's just watch this and it'll be a
good time you know what I mean it's a
great like indie film that is you get
wherever wine um say this uh with any
sort of self boastfulness but um I'm I'm
not in like just one scene this is like
my movie the people like I thought you'd
be in that more I'm in it maybe too much
you could argue stop it no I like do the
opposite I like to be like the things
I'm in the most be like yeah I'm there
and they like Johnny you're in there
yeah uh so it's one called wine club
check that out I have dates uh Daniel
vanan kirk.com I don't know exactly when
this drops I might have been in De Mo
and Cedar Rapids but I will be uh
beginning of March I'm in DC I'm also
going to be in Wisconsin uh I'm do I'm
part of Netflix as a joke at The Bourbon
Room on Mother's Day that's a Sunday
everything is up at Daniel
vank.red
might have been her watching her you the
look at her oh my god oh that's one of
those Teeter hangup see let me see is
that a back thing
the invion therapy table whatever they
call I'm Batman sort of thing this is
just a simple 40 hour ABS third third
third story little dumb person caught
footage captured the embarrassing moment
in Ohio Jim bunny Jim bunny is that word
is that do you have to um touch a
woman's ass when you say that that you
don't know he what I like it's like a
like like a nice female it's like a gy
rat a little gym bunny bu she was ass
over teac bunny you guys want another
round of drinks that's who says Jim
bunny this guy you know it's making me
uncomfortable just let me get a carrot
juice for the gim bunny I mean you guys
are a little bit older than than us but
I'm just saying I always I say this I
have a brother years younger than me and
and when I talk about like technology
and society and stuff I tell people and
maybe it was just Rochelle but I think
it probably holds up for you guys as
well my
childhood is closer to my mother's
experience than it is my brother's who's
8 years younger than me because because
Tech internet and everything dude my
daughters who are two years apart have
like there a massive I remember being in
grade school again this may be a
Rochelle thing because it's a little
small farm town but I remember sinking
up the vinyl record with the real toore
to watch things in class but by the time
I graduated high school we had cell
phones and DVDs Dam that movement is
insane right that is wild but there is
just this gy bunny thing is what I'm
running off of so I apologize but there
is we did live in enough of that era
where there still was the like you men
would just put their hands on the small
of a woman's back that they didn't know
to like order another drink such a wild
just a wild
it's why like whenever I watch Like Old
Mad Men I'm like oh my God like we
remember cigarette ashtrays in
McDonald's oh yeah oh IES people smoke
on the plan yes and you'd sit in the
nonsmoking portion of the plane out in
the back there was uh Polish airlines
this is true this is not a joke Polish
joke I love I love I have a lot of these
in my hour where I tell people go this
isn't even a joke not a joke our friend
went on the march of the living to go to
like the concentration camps in Poland
and he flew on Polish Airlines and he
said the left half of the plane was
smoking and the right half was not this
is even that is like it is true everyone
on the left side of the plane was
smoking everyone on the right side had
to I still do it I walk into a
restaurant and they'll be like uh for
two I go yeah
smoking it needs to come back I really
think that after Co should be like yeah
you guys can smoke in the airports again
now okaywhere just like give it up I'm
not going to smoke but who vaping
section okay where was I poor girl poor
girl yeah this uh gy woman trapped
upside down in exerise equipment and had
been had to be extricated by police this
is so embarrassing Christine F told the
dispatcher after calling 911 in a clip
depicting the freak accident which why
isn't someone else at the gym calling at
because it occurred at 3:00 a.m. while
working out at 24-hour Powerhouse Gym
come on just say you who's taking the
video doesn't someone work there yeah
she's got the key how you get in B she
was reportedly filming herself using the
inversion table a medieval looking
contraption that allegedly e eases
people's back pain by turning them this
allegedly medieval this is all like
someone who doesn't trust the inversion
machine also extricated in a video of
her mishap she said that she had set up
her phone quote to record a video of me
on the inversion table and I'm just
saying how much I love it for my lower
back especially when I'm going to the
gym at 3:00 a.m. and my back is really
stiff and I don't want to wake up okay
we get she must get hit on all the time
at the gym she there's nobody there I
know I'm saying she's like the only time
I can go gy bunny she's like the only
time I go 3:00 a.m. I want to get 3:
a.m. I must be working out it's 3:00
a.m. I must be
hanging and she says
baby I'm stuck in this okay we need to
extricate you from upside down as
however the exercise equipment went
South and so did she that was me after
she became stuck dangling upside down in
the device it wound up being a viral
video in the making mhm then it then it
just caught the whole thing and kept
recording she said of her at the ready
phone actually I had to post it yeah
exactly in one of the humilating clips
folds f a l DS she did post it Dan can
be seen flailing helplessly after
realizing she was trapped at one point
the jym shark the jym shark just shark
now shk oh my God what is this the New
York Post or something like even
attempts to I'm going to tell you it is
the New York oh how do you like that it
is yes the New York Post feels good
feels the New York Post is like the guy
putting his hand on the small but it's
kind of you know you got to admit it's
better than other reading other things
it's nice and fun I want to punch the
New York Post in the face yes I but
that's why it's good it's it evokes an
emotion in it angers you yeah and one of
the the gym shark even attempts to
Crunch her way up to the leg clamps and
undo them
Allah so that's the moment where you're
like I need to work on my abs more cuz
I'm only getting up to my mid th
predicament was particularly dire as
there were only a few other people at
the gym during the overnight hour and
they were in other rooms with music
playing staff was also absent because
users scan key cards for the entrance at
that time the inverted influencer
explained now they have one of these in
Rosell too it's called 24-hour fitness
and I always wonder who goes at 3:00
a.m. there no matter what time I roll
let say I land at Midway at [__]
10:00 I get my rental car I drive out to
Rell it's now it's 11:30 midnight
whatever and I'll look as I drive by and
there are people in there I always
wonder who is that right but then also
what how much is the insurance policy
you have to have to be a gym that allows
people to work out sign you sign a
waiver you sign a waiver when you sign
your contract that like if I'm here in
an hours where no one is here that it is
my responsib everything on me everything
everything's on you thankfully the
Imperial Ohio ohioan was able to use her
Smartwatch who said go Jay said it wow
to dial 911 as seen in the hilarious CL
call police there's only one person at
the gym and I got stuck stuck you know
that backboard thing she could be heard
saying while hanging for her feet from
her feet I'm stuck in Reverse like back
decompression thing reverse stuck in
Reverse reverse she's a human bat
Batwoman I think the thing went how
there hasn't been a batom come on
there's cat there's bat girl there's bad
girl but bad woman come on make it a
mature human being yeah an old bat old
she is a she is a woman that's what's
wild that old bat's flapping around here
again this woman inverted upside down at
the gym she's bad this is an origin
story Dan I think the thing went too far
and I just got stuck upside down and
can't get myself right side up she
continued telling the dispatcher who
didn't care I'm stuck trying to get my
buddy's attention but he's in the other
room lifting I'm sorry I'm just stuck
he's lifting too much and I told him not
to lift with his back like she adds all
these other details in there after
police arrived at the scene and freed
her from the spine decompression how
which how much you want to bet one of
the guys walked in was like get the jaws
of life
bat lady over here how many minutes do
you think she was stuck upside
down 42 42 I'm guessing hon Jackie
Robinson yeah I agree I'm guessing uh 28
28 35 35 in total Falls had been trapped
upside down for 12 minutes oh it's not
that much so you you men she had to call
within the 3 to 5 minute range which
still gives them the cops about 10
minutes to so the cops coming but being
trapped upside down it wouldn't take me
very long to be like I'm
scared if you're trapped did the cops
have to break through the door to get in
no I'm sure they no they had to sign up
for a 12-month
membership you guys do need a pass if
you're going to go back there you do
need a pass you cannot use the sauna or
the shower that would be a funny what do
you mean I have to sorry guys but it's
it's Auto renewed we got to sign you up
I just need a credit got to remember to
cancel if I just let you in and then I
see that you guys are kind of start
working out I'm going to have to let
every first responder in and we we do
have these policies done that in the
past
and want to go help her today I can give
you the passes we will need to do a tour
of the locker rooms before I let you
into that area you could do if you want
to sign up for a a dual black membership
which is a the black Express gold level
you guys can share it and that's you
guys would save $5 a year that's like
four classes a month four classes anyone
you can just drop into you can share
that class and also rolls over but we
have to do cash only cash only and it's
all going to be up front for the first
four years this does this offer does
expire today actually we only take
Travelers checks yeah not even cash
while the exercise Enthusiast wasn't
harmed during the ordeal she said she
doesn't know if she'll ever go on that
table again to be honest which means
she's going to do it I want you on that
table said she'll avoid cuz she put all
this on Tik Tok for a few days she's
going to avoid because it was so
overwhelming that I need a mental break
in retrospect fold said she learned to
see the funny side of her situation did
people are saying why would you post
that so embarrassing 12 minutes in but
I'm like sometimes you got to laugh at
yourself and move on the mortified fit
influencer so is the deal with the post
is that you have to describe them in a
different way
single so wait wait told complex this
woman it's not sometimes you have to
laugh at yourself this woman was like I
will go viral with this I got the I got
the clip I I got it while certainly a
comical situation getting trapped upside
down isn't as humorous as it sounds
according to health line it is possible
to die from hanging upside down for too
long it's rare but blood can pull in the
head which can be extremely dangerous
there you go God Bess God bless the
police department for being there for
her this is when they saved her I see
what she looks like again I'll try yeah
she's a fit influencer guys let me see
she's a she's a gym bunny is she a
bigger person yeah she's a she's a
little bigger she's great good God bless
did the machine break or did she have I
think either it break or it does look
like she's a little inverted like maybe
it went too far by the way that can't be
the kind of thing that you if you can
really get your you can push it down and
then but you can grab those handles the
idea is you grab the handles and you can
throw yourself forward also can't you
like just underne I don't know I don't
know how it goes there's a huge tractor
tire this gy is rough can't she throw
herself onto her side knock the machine
over or something oh my God that would
hurt so bad Randy you break a leg sh all
right that's there you go that's the
story go to Johnny's onean show espe in
Chicago you guys know I know Chicago
people come out go check it out and go
see us go see Dan's movie and uh when a
special comes out we love you guys so
much thanks for supporting us and oh
[__] we got to get back to
work around
[Music]
S's